well I first like my sole contact with
Buckley which was no particular
significance as far as I was concerned
was that he invited me to be on a
program at talk program that he ran
called firing line and yes I was invited
and was there for one one program that
was it you can see the program I
understand that's been now appears on
the internet and so on
at the end he said he was pretty angry
he said he would like me back but of
course I never heard from him again
he was he was the maybe the leading
figure in the so-called conservative
movement I don't think the term
conservative was appropriate but what's
called the conservative movement he was
maybe its leading figure it was maybe
it's leading at lecture all his journal
was the house journal he was considered
not by me but he was considered to be
witty articulate knowledgeable and so on
and much respected again not by me but
I'm giving the general impression the
witch calling his successors I assume
you mean the so-called neoconservatives
I mean they're even farther from
conservatism they're just extreme
radical nationalists Wolfowitz Pearl
Cheney the rest of them it's it's
defaming conservatism to associate them
with conservatism conservatism as an
honorable tradition but it's not that
the same is true of Reagan Reagan was
believed in the military violence and
destruction in Central America virtually
destroyed they supported the South
Africa's apartheid regime and violation
of congressional legislation supported
its attacks on neighboring countries
that killed a million and a half people
supported the Israeli atrocities in
Lebanon killed tens of thousands of
people and so on and internally he was
in favor of large-scale government
intervention
in the economy I mean Reagan was the
most protectionist president in post-war
American history double protectionist
barriers called on the Pentagon to
rescue deficient American management's
teach them modern management techniques
so that they could save the economy from
Japanese takeover I mean to call this
conservatism this bad joke and then
neocon so-called or in more extreme so
by today's standards buckley looks
pretty moderate as